[Musique]
une femme léger j'ai pas vous comptez a
mené samedi si vous mettez 10 kg de noir
êtes vous pour le principe de la maison
close complètement non la maison bien
isolée mur toi fenêtres double vitrage
moi je les pose est chez moi on a gagné
25% de on a fait une économie de 25 % de
chauffage êtes vous pour le ménage à
trois madame oui pourquoi pas parce que
je dis que la fin bref doit être libre
c'est à dire pas tout en étant la maison
à faire le ménage
c'est normal que colmar y est si tout le
monde travaille on me dit que sont la
femme et les chiens sa liberté comme
tout le monde
que connaissez-vous comme ce catalogue
alors je connais je tenais de préférence
des 3 suisses et puis la redoute
l'homosexualité ça ne vous dit rien
absolument pas non non en tant que les
six voeux aux mots je comprends on s'en
sert pour la lessive enfin pour le
ménage quoi mais cette histoire de
d'homosexualité j'avoue que tout autre
en savon pourrait très bien remplacer
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que c'est
votre avis c'est les juifs et sionistes
sioniste veut dire juif est alors
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que ça
serait le retour des juifs en israël
nymphomane où vous voyez ce que ça
signifie monsieur qu'est ce que c'est
l'information ce qui fait la formation
alors parmi les nymphomanes qui
connaissait vos valeurs si tron morosi
et puis d'arvor il informe anne et
emilie loit puis iata
[Musique]